when the ones who tell the truth are the
ones who sit in jail we don't have
democracy it seems our system failed
we've got to fight with all our money
together you and me let us thank Bradley
Manning let us set him free we've gotta
stop them where are all rights gotta
stop sleeping stand up and fight Rancher
voices make a fuss because Bradley Manny
speaks for all of us I am Matthew Fein
with recent TV we're here at Fort Meade
in Maryland covering the free Bradley
Manning protest where hundreds of
colorful and boisterous protesters are
protesting the upcoming trial of Private
Bradley Manning let's see what they have
to say I was in the air force from 2004
to 2010 I served in Afghanistan and 2008
with the army I'm here today because
Bradley Manning exposed some of the war
crimes and I wasn't brave enough to
expose and we need to be here to support
him he's given us a look inside the way
this government bullies pushes around
whole country's the way its treated the
Guantanamo prisoners the way it's
treated other prisoners of war
for the first time and the photos of
white animal prisoners his the pages
that the new york times and why did they
even have these photos WikiLeaks do you
believe the government should be ought
to have any secrets so that it should
all be out in public I think the problem
in America since 911 is that the whole
dynamic has changed where even 20 years
ago in general private people and
citizens could expect that they had some
privacy from government prying and and
the government was supposed to be open
and transparent in general but this is
now completely switched the government
has that has all the secrecy I don't
think Bradley Manning should be in jail
at all i don't think whistleblowers that
are exposing war crimes should be in
jail i think that should be encouraged
not punished i believe that the American
people have been misled and that the
truth deserves to be out there so that
the American people as well as the rest
of off make informed decisions about
what we're doing what are your thoughts
about how the current administration has
been dealing with the case I think it's
been at an atrocity I I can't see I
cannot condemn harshly enough the Obama
administration on the Bradley Manning
case
are you optimistic about Bradley
Manning's future I'm hoping that Bradley
Manning can get a fair trial and get a
decent I mean he's already admitted
guilt in some of these charges whatever
happens in the trial and I'm certainly
personally not very optimistic that
Bradley is going to hit justice and
after all this is a military court I
skeptical about how fair the trial will
be and thank you so much for coming to
support Bradley and telling the truth
about his confinement what is it that
your government's doing torturing people
he said I did this because I thought of
regular people knew what their
government was doing it would start a
conversation this is an age where people
are becoming more involved in trying to
shape their government's policies and
for that we need whistleblowers for that
we need leakers for that we need people
who are willing to risk their own job
and their own career and their own
future for the sake of a more peaceful
world